what you have here are another ten short
less than two-minute clips all of these
pertaining to critical thinking many of
them asked of me while I was engaged in
teaching and developing critical
thinking classes for faithfully State
University where I used to teach several
years ago and all of these are coming
from vu which was a social network that
relied on users to record using their
webcam so not really high-quality record
video responses to questions and
comments and so I asked my students in
my critical thinking classes if they if
they wanted to you know raise questions
with me or explore the digital universe
if they wanted to try out vu and so
quite a few of them did respond to the
challenge and so you get ten clips here
not all these are actually coming from
my own students some of these were
coming from V users but I would say a
good six or seven of these particular
questions or comments came from from my
own classes
thinking in there earlier years of age
yes definitely as a matter of fact I
think that if you don't you're actually
handicapping the kid and that's why so
many students come to my classes not
knowing what kids 20 30 40 years ago
would have known and we have to do a lot
of remedial work with critical thinking
I think it's partly because the the
educators themselves k through 12 often
don't have any notion of what critical
thinking actually means other than they
think it means you know looking at
things from different sides and and
asking questions but critical thing is a
lot more than that the the focus on
argument is really key see here's the
thing throughout history part of being
an educated person met studying argument
after argument after argument learning
how to coherently express yourself how
to look at other people's arguments
which are often quite complex I mean
just think about the argumentative
structure and as simple as a document as
letter from a Birmingham jail which
apparently students don't read anymore
Martin Luther King assumed an audience
that actually was educated well enough
to follow arguments and if you don't
have that it's just a lot of gobbly [ __ ]
to you with a few you know Pius
sentiments thrown in if you actually can
look at arguments and it takes a lot of
practice to be able to do that to be
able to understand what an author is
doing if you can do that then are done
it opens up an entire world for you the
whole world of the humanities really
depends on people being able to think
not just appreciate but but think and so
critical thinking yeah we ought to be
teaching our kids that it ought to be a
deliberately infused part of the
curriculum right now it's not I don't
know if that's going to change in the
future
yes I think critical thinking should be
taught in high school and I think it
should be taught in two different ways I
think that it should actually be taught
as portions of a course modules you
might say and I think that it should be
infused into the curriculum in high
school as well one thing I find is that
education people that I deal with they
have an understanding of critical
thinking that does not match up to or
measure up to what we philosophers
actually mean by critical thinking and
if you want to know what critical
thinking means the best place to go is
the american philosophical association
delphi report and in other countries
actually they do teach a lot of what we
call critical thinking in their their
equivalents of high school so i think
that we ought to be doing that i'm not
sure how you would actually get it in
there they would take quite a bit of
work but i think that that's something
that we really need because one of the
things I'm finding is students are
coming students are coming into my
critical thinking classes and they are
just not prepared at all so we have to
do a lot of remedial work
so here's a question from one of my
students do you think that critical
thinking is mainly common sense and the
answer's no I think that critical
thinking and common sense are connected
in very interesting ways I'm going to
try to be really short here so here's
what I have to say critical thinking
goes beyond common sense it builds on it
and I think it presupposes it but
critical thinking as a discipline means
the study of argumentation learning how
to analyze arguments that means break
them into their parts how to evaluate
them tell whether they're good arguments
or bad arguments how to look to see
whether premises or starting points of
arguments are actually true or not how
to evaluate information sources there's
more to critical thinking than that but
you notice that goes beyond just common
sense and it goes beyond common sense
because it presupposes it but it also
goes beyond it because there's certain
methods and common sense doesn't really
have methods I think that common sense
is something that you really have to
have some mo to come up in order to be
able to do any critical thinking
so here's another question good question
about critical thinking and common sense
what is the difference between critical
thinking and common sense so when I
thought about this I came up with three
what is that critical thinking actually
builds on common sense to some degree
and it codifies it and it extends it so
if you don't have some degree of common
sense the critical thinking might not do
you quite that much good the critical
thinking goes beyond common size so
that's one thing second one I notice you
can have a critical thinking textbook do
you have a common sense textbook no
because common sense is sort of a set of
habits that are that are built up
situationally over time critical
thinking can actually be taught because
it consists in some techniques and
concepts procedures and definitions
that's why it's tied in logic logic can
be taught to third thing common sense
can't actually take stock of and explain
itself you have common sense you use
common sense if somebody asks you what's
common sense you have a very difficult
time saying what it is critical thinking
can actually take account of itself and
provide reasons why it makes the
judgments it does if you have common
sense you you generally make the right
determinations right but you can't say
exactly why you can you just say wants
common sense the critical thinking you
should be able to give some sort of
reason why something is a good argument
for a bad argument well it has this
fallacy or you know the premises are
false notice what you're doing there
goes beyond common sense so I hope that
helps
so this is by one of my critical
thinking students is it better to be a
skeptical thinker or a critical thinker
that depends entirely on what you mean
by skeptical there's two main ways that
I'm going to talk about here so if you
means by skeptical looking for evidence
that's proportionate to the sort of
claims that people are making that's
part of being a critical thinker
actually that that should be something
you're applying not only to other people
but also to yourself so when you say to
yourself I should do this or I shouldn't
do that part of being a critical thinker
is actually being skeptical of your own
desires responses and that doesn't mean
saying hey they can't there can't be
anything to them it just means looking
for some evidence looking for some
reasons for what you're saying if you
mean by skeptical the kind of person who
doesn't believe anything and makes
exorbitantly high demands for for
evidence from people that can't possibly
be met yeah that's no good you don't
want that so that's not being a critical
thinker and if that's what you mean by a
skeptical thinker I'd much rather see
you be a critical thinker than a
skeptical thinker
what am I supposed to do with this
critical thinking now that I've known as
your class my hope is that you'll
continue with what you've learned in the
class was of course assuming that you've
actually put in the necessary work to
have gotten much out of the class which
I would say only a third of my students
do in any given semester what are you
supposed to be you're supposed to build
upon the foundation that we worked with
in the class and you're supposed to
extend it and you're supposed to make
this part of your set of tools or you
might think of it as part of your
skeleton of your thought you know
there's a lot of areas in which critical
thinking and the skills and the
dispositions that it comprises like you
know for instance giving reasons that
other people might find convincing for
the claims that you're making or looking
for other people to give reasons
similarly that that's a habit that's not
something that you just automatically
grasp and start doing you've got to
build that up as part of your or your
repertoire your way of communicating
with other people your way of being I
hope that you do build on it because I
think this stuff is really important and
I can pick out four main areas where
it's critically important one is in your
other classes you know you need to be
able to make arguments to look at other
people's arguments to evaluate
information sources to compare positions
against each other to give explanations
for what's going on and also reducing
self scrutiny and so that you can prove
politics is another really important
area we're
where you have to apply critical
thinking and the marketplace you know as
a consumer you need to be able to apply
critical thinking and then your personal
life a lot of arguments that people get
into when you look at them carefully a
lot of what therapists are actually
doing is pointing out errors and
critical thinking that they're your
clients are making so that's why it's
important
do I think that students we use critical
thinking after they've left my class I
know that some of them do because I do
have students who come up to me and
it'll be out of the blue they see me on
campus and they say hey that that thing
that we learned in your class this topic
I ended up using it in another class or
you know I was watching the news and and
I realized that they weren't giving me
the whole story because or I was tempted
to buy this product but then I started
looking closely at the advertisement and
analyzing it so I know that people are
using some of the things they have to do
they leave the class and a lot of the
students have actually said that the
focus on argument and being able to make
arguments to compose them really helped
them a lot in their writing in other
classes my hope of course as an educator
is that all the students continue to
practice what we learn in the critical
thinking classes the reality is I think
most of the students actually just get
through the class and then forget about
it which is terrible because when it
comes to voting consuming being
productive members of society they
they're at a disadvantage and they're
actually going to be a problem for their
fellow citizens family members they're
contributing to a marketplace where
people are able to exploit each other
very very easily critical thinking is
actually you might say kind of a duty
for an educated person so that's why we
teach it that's why it's a required
class of Fayetteville State University
it's not in a lot of places should be
should be required everywhere but
unfortunately it's not
worse if you read your textbook on page
36 that's recovered this right now yeah
this is from one of my critical thinking
students and it's a very legitimate
question how does critical thinking
prepare us for the world outside of
college and you know I spend some of the
class time talking about how what we're
doing in the critical thinking class
which deals with building blocks of
arguments how to analyze arguments how
to evaluate arguments how to look at
larger arguments with information
sources how to evaluate them with issues
of bias the informal fallacies and then
with some of the basics of inductive
techniques of inductive reasoning I
often stress that this is really useful
for your other classes but that's a
legitimate question what good is this
stuff once we actually get out of
college and I think that you know if you
look at the examples in in my course
lectures that I've put online for for
you guys you notice that I give a lot of
useful examples not from other classes
but from real life ranging from politics
to products to things about stereotyping
personal relationships all those sorts
of things usually when we make bad
choices bad inferences when we get into
heated arguments with people it's
because some sort of failure of critical
thinking has taken place and it may not
be right there in that that there we go
right there in the argument that you're
looking at it may be of a larger context
and this actually some type of fusion
few seconds left critical thinking is
not just a set of techniques it's not
just a set of skills it's not just
knowledge it's also dispositions and
that disposition to look at the larger
context and to self-evaluate that's
really core to critical thinking so and
that's important in life
what is a good deductive argument well
this one is actually very
straightforward and simple to answer a
good deductive argument is one which is
both valid and sound so valid means that
it has a good structure the nice thing
about deductive arguments is you can
analyze them solely in terms of their
structure if you want to and that's what
formal logic is is all about you can
symbolize them with with you know
various symbols that we use and with
letters or any other kind of variables
that you like and you can look just at
the form and if the premises being true
would lead to the conclusion being true
then it's valid and there's a number of
different techniques that we have in my
critical thinking class unfortunately
since we didn't have a time we didn't go
into it but there are a lot of really
quite interesting I find them very
interesting and a lot of people in math
and computer science find them very
interesting as well a lot of interesting
techniques that you can use to to
analyze deductive arguments the other
part of it is it needs it has to be
sound which means that the premises
actually have to be true now determining
whether premises are actually true
that's a bit different than just looking
at the structure of things sometimes it
means actually looking at the world or
comparing what you know in your
background knowledge or in your field of
expertise with the claims that are being
made so yeah that's that's a that's what
it takes just has to be valid and sound
this is the most interesting critical
thinking question yet that I've been
asked does writing music require
critical thinking skills and the answer
is no you don't need argument or you
know the ability to distinguish claims
from each other or you know concerns
about information sources or things like
that and credibility to write music but
you do in fact need some of the same
basic dispositions that you would need
in order to be a critical thinker in
order to write music well you have to
have persistence you have to actually be
willing to dig into the topic you know
music is complex music theory it really
helps to know some mathematics in order
to make sense out of that not only do
you have to have a good year you have to
have a good brain and so yeah it doesn't
require critical thinking skills per se
but it requires something that's in the
same sort of family as critical thinking
skills I think